est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique ce soir c'est william and kate
avec nous en plateau alors pour parler
de prévention contre le sida mais aussi
de musique tout à fait alors plutôt d'un
festival qui regroupe prévention et
musique je veux bien entendu parler de
solidays de l'événement de solidarité
sida qui est devenue maintenant
incontournable en ile-de-france un
festival dont l'objectif est la récolte
de fonds pour la lutte contre le sida
comme l'année dernière ça se passera à
l'hippodrome de longchamp du 24 au 26
juin il y aura plus de 80 concerts avec
des têtes d'affiché comme oxmo puccino
qu'oxmo puccino keziah jones
ibrahim maalouf cypress hill ou encore
louise attaque jeudi dernier nous étions
à la conférence de presse du lancement
de l'événement qui cette année prend le
nom de solidays of love qui s'inspirent
du mouvement américain summer of love
est séduite baroin lors de directeur qui
nous explique pourquoi c'est un
mouvement né de la jeunesse dans les
années 65 1967 qui né à san francisco et
en gros c'était un mouvement pacifique
pacifiste il ya eu une dizaine de jeunes
des dizaines de jeunes des centaines des
milliers d à dominer des centaines de
milliers comment dès la fin de la guerre
au vietnam et qui ont de demander la fin
de la discrimination entre noirs et
blancs et donc voilà ça déboucher sur un
mouvement sociétal qui a dépassé tout le
monde même les médias et donc notre idée
c'est d'essayer de faire un parallèle
entre le mouvement de jeunesse de san
francisco donc le festival ici dépasse
le cadre de la lutte juste contre le
sida oui justement même si c'est plutôt
reste la vocation première est la raison
pour laquelle les artistes se mobilisent
pendant ces trois jours solidays est un
festival qui se veut humaniste et comme
l'a dit son directeur et fondateur qui
traite de plusieurs sujets de société on
le voit avec les artistes invités qui ne
sont pas tous des chanteurs l'année
dernière yann arthus-bertrand présenter
son film human en projection au festival
cette année c'est le photoreportage qui
est à l'honneur avec la présence de deux
expositions la première c'est celle de
résa conçu spécialement pour solidays et
la seconde c'est celle de dan ar qui est
actuellement en exposition au palais de
tokyo et qui traite évidemment de thèmes
d'actualité son exposition s'intitule à
jan willem et a pour but de redonner une
identité aux réfugiés dont elle a suivi
le parcours de ce boss à munich en les
photographiant nous l'avons rencontrée
et elle nous en parle c'est des gens qui
ne peuvent pas faire machine arrière et
donc il raconte le possible d'un
ailleurs mais aussi raconte le possible
avec nous je suis très fier que bouchra
naouar ali farid mohamed et l'âme
zahara soit debout dans les solidays et
comme homos
on célèbre l'engagement le vivre
ensemble que ya toujours un point de
notre cerveau et notre regard qui fait
qu'on les regarde quoi donc céder c'est
clairement un festival engagé oui c'est
un festival qui s'engagent surtout il ne
faut pas oublier que l'objectif c'est
surtout de récolter des fonds pour la
lutte contre le sida le festival a donc
fait une grande place à la prévention en
invitant de nombreuses associations
comme hf prévention que nous conte que
nous connaissons bien un téléfilm et qui
sera sur place pendant trois jours pour
l'ubs avril le directeur cette année est
aussi une année très importante car la
france va devoir se prononcer sur le
montant de sa contribution au fonds
monde est en fond mondial de lutte
contre le sida une contribution qui va
être impactée par les recettes du
festival qui continue qui se constitue
une aide majeure pardon pour ce fonds
solidays un festival qui ne pourraient
également pas existé non plus sans
l'aide des bénévoles ils sont plus de
3000 chaque année à prendre de leur
temps pour venir installer et organiser
l'événement moi ce que je préfère en
fait c'est aller faire ma pub dit au
village associatif
parce que
où aller dire bonjour aux bénévoles
tous les gens qu'on pose sur le festival
ils sont 2000 quand même à nous
permettent de réaliser ce truc là il ya
certains de nos bénévoles composée trois
semaines de vacances sur le sens qu'ils
ont à l'année pour faire le montage
démontage d'exploitation ils viennent de
la france entière voilà moi j'ai un
profond respect pour eux et je pense que
cette l'esprit si particulier qui règne
à solidays ils ont pour beaucoup parce
qu'ils en sont à la fois les principaux
moteurs et les principaux ambassadeurs
les bénévoles qui seront remerciés
chaque année comme il se doit par les
organisateurs avec une soirée en leur
honneur mais le festival a également de
nombreux partenaires et la région ile de
france et d'ailleurs le premier
partenaire carla participe à hauteur de
800 1000 euros chaque année alors on
savait jean paul huchon jean paul huchon
ancien président de la région grand
rockeur est aussi très attaché au
festival la région ayant changé de
gouvernance on a demandé à valérie
pécresse la nouvelle présidente de
région sur quelle scène à l'aller plutôt
se rendre au mais moi j'adore l'électro
donc je pense que je suis plus en phase
avec la programmation de solides et
peut-être que mon prédécesseur parce que
le rock c'est plutôt à saint claud et
c'est plutôt rock en seine voilà alors
on a fait un rapide tour du festival qui
sera d'ailleurs encore plus grand cette
année avec cinq hectares supplémentaires
trois nouvelles scènes pour la
découverte de nouveaux artistes et
beaucoup d'autres espaces en plus brefs
solidays un festival qui n'arrête pas
d'évoluer j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
annoncer que terry fils sera là bas le
temps d'un week end pour une émission
spéciale avec jérôme andré directeur de
hf prévention mais aussi de tous les
artistes qu'on pourra croiser d'ailleurs
les artistes on les écoute je suis
engagé en tant qu'artiste parce que
parce qu'on a une voix données et je
suis engagé humainement parce qu'il
s'agit aussi de préserver la vie il
s'agit de promouvoir l'amour est pour
moi le sida est un et en tue l'amour et
donc
nous sommes là pour la pole pour le
combattre c'est une affiche qui est qui
qui appelle peace and love c'est à dire
le pouvoir de la fleur et puis des
sourires et finalement c'est ce qu'on a
besoin je crois que depuis cro magnon
jusqu à cosmos 1999 dans l'avenir
c'est ça c'est peace and love donc
évidemment que je suis je suis merci
williams alors je le rappelle est solide
et c'est du 24 au 26 juin ou à
l'hippodrome de longchamp vous y
retrouvera